oh my god you guys seriously yeah
it's not sending out notifications it's
just [ __ ] up i don't you know what i
don't even give a [ __ ] anymore you don't
give a [ __ ] anymore it's like seriously
there's some people on there
i am like [ __ ] a quarter away maybe
two-thirds of the way through the notes
yeah i can't even get through my [ __ ]
notes and like [ __ ] is like pretty and
you know what i'm like look if it goes
off again i'm just going to bed
yeah and we'll talk about the rest of 13
o'clock history and we'll talk about the
rest of the [ __ ] tomorrow
yeah something's wrong because
i don't know we pay a lot for this
internet connection and
i don't understand what the problem the
fact that it is not working
it's saying it's slow but we don't have
a lot of devices on right now
you know what i mean we're not running a
hole which i'm gonna kill a [ __ ]
right now
yeah and can we please my smart tv was
running fine all day today
that's what i mean yeah i don't know i
don't know what it is what's it saying
about the [ __ ]
the speed well let's find out
oh sounds bad yep there goes yellow
again is this the [ __ ] camera
the camera is not involved in it man
anything can be involved unplug that
[ __ ] and plug it back in
no no no see if it does something to it
please don't cry don't okay don't okay
[ __ ] with my [ __ ] i said something i
tried to fix it people
no you didn't i would unplug that camera
and plug it back in you don't know how
anything works i don't know how
everything works no you don't you don't
know it anything works
and you try to like unplug things and
it's like i have everything set up the
way i want it to set up
okay yeah
victor says you guys should have a tech
to come over and check out your [ __ ]
well yeah
because well no we should take five days
five days for a [ __ ] to get here and
then they try to sell you some other
[ __ ]
auto just [ __ ] uh change companies
who do we have is it at t or is it uh
direct tv
or whatever i don't know we have like
[ __ ]
the cable on the internet is all bundled
can we please talk about waco for a
little while
at least until it crashes if it crashes
again like i said i'm just yeah mark sam
look calm down breathe in breathe
breathe out that's what i'm telling her
mark
she's getting too wrapped up you're
getting two are you getting two
yeah but you have to understand look we
can always figure this [ __ ] out tomorrow
it's
i've spent before or five days
researching this [ __ ]
it's probably because it's a saturday
and the traffic's [ __ ] heavy
well i know that but i haven't had like
this problem
we have the problem on the jonestown
show sure one time
this is the first time that we've had
this happen multiple times
and it's really starting to get on my
nerves
so like i said i've spent four or five
days researching this [ __ ] if i can't
even talk about the [ __ ]
then if it happens another time i'm just
going to bed
yeah and i will talk about it tomorrow
okay go ahead go ahead so i'm just
saying
let's go all right so we're getting to
the point where
i don't even remember where the [ __ ] i
was all right so
like i said there were a lot of
allegations of
child abuse going on at this [ __ ]
compound
and you know david koresh saying like
hey woo i
married a [ __ ] 12 year old because
apparently he wasn't
ashamed of it so there was all of that
going on
now um
what ended up happening was that the
uh atf were looking into the cult
because of the child
abuse allegations and also because
a ups driver had
informed them that they're like hey um
we had a package that was coming into
this compound
and it broke open and there was a bunch
of [ __ ] in there that was like
not kosher there was like a bunch of um
you know empty uh grenades with like
some black powder
like some [ __ ] m16 parts or whatever
so it was like some [ __ ] that wasn't
so he thought that he should probably
report it so the ups driver reported it
to the atf so at this point that like i
said there had been like some
allegations of child abuse child sexual
abuse
and also some illegal weapons [ __ ] going
on at this compound
so the atf decides to put this compound
under surveillance so
they put them under surveillance now
what they did at first
was that and this is uh kind of funny
was that they had these four guys that
said that they were college students i
guess and they
rented the property across from
where the um you know where the
where the mount carmel like uh compound
was
and they were gonna like watch them
now even though they were supposed to be
college students that were living at
this
property um they were clearly in their
30s or 40s
which a little old for college students
all of them had really really nice
clothes like really nice suits
all of them had brand new cars so a lot
of the
um members of the branch davidians were
like yeah those are probably feds
because it's like college students are
one not that old
and two they don't have that nice cars
or clothes
so something weird is obviously going on
so
they obviously knew that very early on
something was going on with that [ __ ]
even though atf tried really hard to
make it seem like it wasn't them
so basically what happened was that
so one of the dudes that was
like had them under surveillance now
i will give it to the branch davidians
they did like befriend that dude now
they were pretty sure they weren't
entirely sure
but they were pretty convinced this is
probably an undercover federal agent
because we know these are not
college students we know college
students are not going to be
renting this property it just seemed
very strange to them
so they were pretty aware that this is
probably
people that have us under surveillance
you know what i mean so
they weren't dumb um they knew that
that's
what was going on so
uh david koresh and his uh right-hand
man
uh kind of befriended one of the dudes
because they were kind of like well he
seemed like a nice guy
like we knew that he was probably an
undercover agent and that he had us
under surveillance
but he was also kind of a nice dude so
we were kind of like talking to him and
you know all this other kind of stuff
now
the thing about it is that so
um from the surveillance that the atf
had even though as i said their their
cover was kind of blown from the
beginning
they did get a search warrant because a
lot of the
um intel that they were getting said
that the branch davidians had
it wasn't just so much that they had a
stockpile of weapons which they did
um but i mean they admitted a lot of the
weapons that they had were legal
and you know there was nothing wrong
with that but they did say well
there were some things that they were
getting which were illegal
like some parts for modifying
semi-automatic to
automatic weapons which again illegal
they were trying to make things into
machine guns which
again illegal they said a lot of the
things that they had were fine
and they weren't worried about it but
the ups driver that kind of turned them
in because they were like grenades and
whatnot
they were kind of like okay well maybe
somebody needs to look into that
and so that's kind of how that kind of
[ __ ] started
yeah all right let me let me jump in on
that what they did is they had [ __ ] like
templates
to show you where to drill holes in
certain receivers
and then they had trigger parts kids
which that's not illegal that's that's
that's legal to have
the thing is though is that they can
come at you kind of sideways
and say it's conspiracy
to fab to to manufacture you know what i
mean
but according to the davidians they were
gonna
convert their semi-auto [ __ ] to full
auto [ __ ] once the apocalypse had
happened that's that's what they were
gonna do
well and as i said anyone they wouldn't
have got busted for the conspiracy
no that's never gone through a lot of
people been hit with that
and it's just it just doesn't doesn't
stand up in court usually
well the thing about and like i said
earlier it's like it's kind of like
nobody like look there's a lot of cults
operating in the u.s and they operate
completely you know they just do what
they do and it's fine
but i think the problem arises one would
you believe that you're special
which believing that you're special um
you know that's kind of
um you know believing that you're
special kind of believes that everyone
else is
below you in some way so that kind of
justifies a lot of bad behavior
and also the fact that you kind of think
that
i kind of feel like there's this whole
thing too where a lot of these types of
groups feel like they're being
victimized we talked about this a little
bit on the jonestown show too
because even though they were in another
country
um i kind of feel like they weren't
being victimized until
like somebody just came down there to
like check out what the [ __ ] they were
doing and they only came down there to
check out what the [ __ ] they were doing
is because like some relatives of people
that were down there were like yeah i
heard some bad [ __ ] about that like can
you please like check out and see if my
relative is okay and then they kind of
interpret that
as everyone's coming at me
so armageddon time so i kind of feel
like that's
a little bit what went on in this
situation too
but as i said i'm not letting the atf
off the hook because they should have
listened to
the cult experts because the cult
experts were saying
exactly that they were saying look you
know we studied jonestown we did all
that kind of [ __ ] it's like you can't
you can't go in there like pretending
that
you're going to like pull people out or
what because they will just double down
and they will fight back against you and
it will be ugly
and all the cult experts told them that
and they kind of went ahead anyway well
you're
feeding right into their narrative that
exactly and particularly in this
situation
and in the jonestown situation too
because their whole narrative was like
what everyone's out to get us it's going
to be like the end of the world it's
like a big so that's their narrative
so anything that plays into that is just
gonna like make them double down on
their beliefs because it looks like
their beliefs are coming to pass
everyone is coming to pick on them
everyone is coming to like [ __ ] even
if that's not really what's happening
but that's how they're going to
interpret it
well they thought the federal government
was like the uh
the beast from revelations yeah and it
was going to come and [ __ ] them up
and uh it was gonna like oppress them
which it kind of was
because korres was going around marrying
12 year old girls
well yeah which so of course they're
going to come stop that yeah that's not
going to be allowed
he's looking in the doubt he's looking
in his scriptures and he's going like
well this is from god
well it should be allowed because god
says that i should be able to marry as
many people
that's just the mindset and that's the
mindset
i know that's the way they are and like
i said that's why i mean they did
consult
called experts like rick ross and other
people and he was like yeah
just don't attack them at least
forthright because they will take that
as you know foundation validation of
what they're saying
so and that will just make them double
down and they'll fight back worse
against you and
so everything will get really really bad
which is
spoiler alert what ended up happening
yeah and
they didn't care really because they
thought it was end times anyway
they thought it was end times apocalypse
[ __ ] you know i mean [ __ ]
the damn lamb is opening the scrolls and
all that you know what i mean and
wormwood is falling into the ocean
destroying one quarter of the damn fish
and one quarter other down
boats and you know that's that's what
they think is going on
so you're not gonna be able to reason
with that not in the not even and i
think that government
that was kind of the failure on and
you know like i said i can't [ __ ] on too
much because
when you're in the atf or you're in the
fbi you're kind of
operating under the assumption that
you're going to be able to reason
with people as though they are actually
have
normal human reasoning but if you're in
a cult like this
it's not the same they're not going to
react to you the same way that
perhaps a normal person yeah right
they're normal people of
normal intelligence some of them are
very intelligent it's just that their
frame of reference
is that's what i'm saying it's not it is
is it is from it's from [ __ ] theology
right in mythology
right so they're not gonna they're not
living in the same universe that you're
in
and i think a lot of like a lot of
documentaries i saw about this like a
lot of the atf and fbi agents
they realized that in the aftermath they
were like look we were approaching this
as though these were rational people
that you could rationalize with like a
normal person
and it's like it's only after it all
happened that we realized
that these are not people that you can
reason with in the same way that you
would be able to reason with because
they actually believed
that the end of the world was coming and
that us
coming there with the tanks and
everything like that that was what was
predicted and so it was really hard for
them to get their heads around that
you know what i'm saying yeah and the
federal troops were sick of being out
out there well they were because it had
been like almost it had been like a
month and a half
they had been out there like every day
like just waiting
and also i should say too that they'd
been [ __ ] around by david koresh
because he kept saying yeah i'll let
these people out and he did let some
people out very early
um like some children and stuff but then
after a while he's like yeah i'll let
some people out oh well
we'll all come out once i write my you
know
essay about the seven seals and all that
other kind of [ __ ] and then
he said he was gonna do that and then
he's like oh it's done but oh never mind
i'm not going to do that now
so it's like so they were kind of used
to being [ __ ] around by him
and they were kind of sick of it i love
all that [ __ ] which like i said
i can see this i love all this i can see
that about the [ __ ] lamb with the
seven horns
and the [ __ ] seven seals oh they were
all i love all that well he was all into
this yeah i love all that [ __ ]
it's just imagery you know what i mean
it is yeah if i ever feel that they're
[ __ ] coming after me i started
thinking that says oh yeah
that's right yeah right they're gonna
get me to accept the mark
then you throw in some danzig and that
confirms it
do you wear the mark
dude i mean [ __ ] dancing
okay i'm not gonna talk about dancing
because i'm gonna get ready to go go
well yeah because you're gonna go off
and i'm gonna go over that thing and i'm
just like look i still have
more than half of the [ __ ] to go okay
all right so how's the stream looking
people look at me
i don't have any color what is it
it says excellent maybe they're working
on our internet
maybe why would they work on some [ __ ]
on a saturday
well i don't know they're working stuff
all the time
i know i know you like to like
conspiracy theory i'm gonna break a
contract with those [ __ ]
y'all never seen me break the contract i
will break a contract with a
[ __ ] in a heartbeat okay
breaking contracts all right so
evidently let's
let's talk about this so the atf as i
said now
initially their plan and what they had a
warrant for
was they were only supposed to arrest
david koresh
uh for illegal weapons violations and
lesser the child abuse um stuff which
like i said which
a lot of people had reported they didn't
have any [ __ ] proof
of but they were kind of looking looking
into it because of that
so they planned their raid for march the
first 1983 now the code name was
uh showtime that was the name of their
of their operation now
they said later that they had
actually moved it up a day to february
28th because
what actually ended up happening was
that the waco tribune herald
had published this series of articles um
called the sinful messiah which was all
about
david koresh and his followers
and apparently there had been some big
back and forth between the atf and
between the media and they're like
please don't
print that and they were like no we have
to print that blah blah so they were
like having this whole thing
and they were uh okay so
it ended up coming out that series
on february 28 or 20 or the day before
that
so the atf were like well okay well we
have to do this earlier than we
expected then because we don't want them
to be
like tipped off about the [ __ ] because
you know
there was that whole thing like like i
said there was a back and forth about it
but
you know he left his glasses there
like right now [ __ ] okay so
what ended up happening though was that
i feel like the atf what okay their
major mistake
i feel like was that
initially their plan was
that they were going to raid the
compound
because the only um you know the only
arrest warrant they had was for david
koresh
so they were going to go into the
compound and arrest him and that was
pretty much the only [ __ ] that they were
going to do
but because the media had printed some
[ __ ] beforehand
because for whatever reason that's not
what ended up happening
and also it should be noted that when
the fbi or when the atf planned the
siege
they planned to have the element of
surprise but what ended up happening was
that
as i mentioned earlier the undercover
agents
that had rented the building across the
street from them
claiming to be college students except
clearly not
um so the thing about it was that the
branch davidians
knew very well that these were uh
agents that were had them under
surveillance
so they were kind and they befriended a
couple of them i'm not saying that but
they were just kind of like yeah well
we know the atf or the fbi has a center
surveillance so it wasn't a big shock to
them
so the fact that there was like a raid
um
ensuing they kind of already knew about
that
so the element of surprise was lost
now at this stage the atf knew
look um you know your
your agent that was in there that
befriended them
um his cover is blown they know
that he is a an atf agent
they know that a siege is in a
is imminent so
probably we should call this [ __ ] off
and like some
people like up in authority said yeah we
should call the [ __ ] off because our
cover's blown it's like they know
that we're gonna do it our you know our
element of surprise
is gone so blah blah but
somebody said no man we're like sick of
the [ __ ] we're just going in
it's like we don't care that they know
that we're coming
and that's probably
i think that was probably the biggest
mistake
in this [ __ ] [ __ ] because i feel like
if they had
they were they were going into it
thinking i mean when they
um designed this
you know raid they were going into is
like oh well
nobody's going to know about it we we
did all this [ __ ] under cover we're
going to go in as we have the element of
surprise
if you don't have that anymore i feel
like maybe you should call that off
and they did discuss it but
they went in anyway even though
the branch davidians knew
they knew that those people across the
street that was
undercover agents they knew that there
was a sage coming they knew
and so that [ __ ] was all just a big show
so like i said i feel like
they probably should have and like i
said there was a big schism because
like some agents were like yeah we
shouldn't do it because you know we
thought we were gonna have the element
of surprise now we don't have that
anymore because they know that we're
coming in
yeah we shouldn't do it yeah but they're
all but then they did it and they
shipped it off
man they're ready to go they're getting
ready
and no that that [ __ ] was all [ __ ]
they should have
all they had to do is just wait in town
wait for david crush to show up and
arrested him on some kind of charges
they didn't have charges then they just
[ __ ] kind of arrested him and bring
him in for questioning and talk to him
and tell them well they did
like [ __ ] up we're gonna we're gonna
[ __ ] the thing about it was that
i kind of feel like what the atf said
afterward was that
well we knew that david korash came into
town
um you know most days and we were
supposed to
pick him up because like i said the only
um you know the only warrant they had
was against him so we were supposed to
pick him up while he was like out in
town
but for whatever reason because the you
know because they called already knew
that that was going to happen he didn't
go that day
for whatever reason so they were kind of
like
you know that that was the excuse that
they gave karesh
koresh weighed a buck 35 tops
i mean three guys [ __ ] could you
could have just piled on him and
immediately
brought him under control with no
problem two guys could do it one
probably
but it's just ah no they were just
trying to put on a big show i think i
think a lot of it had to do with
kind of paramilitary types in the atf
giving a line of [ __ ] to janet reno
because janet reno [ __ ] approved it
and uh she just believed what they told
her
and that [ __ ] was a [ __ ] you know
what i mean she didn't have well like i
said it wasn't
it was just like everybody had
information that
maybe wasn't and it just seemed like it
just turned to this big [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah a big cholesterol that's what it
was
and so the thing that okay so let's talk
about
i got some tea in there if i can borrow
one okay
so let's talk about the siege and the
raid and all that kind of stuff
because like i said it wasn't just a
raid it was like a raid then it was a
siege and that was like a month and a
half
so what ended up happening like i said
the cover was blown for the undercover
agent so like already the branch
davidians
knew that the atf were going to or were
had the
um you know the compound under
surveillance
so they knew that some bad [ __ ] was
going to go down
um they had been stockpiling weapons for
a very long time whether they were legal
or
illegal i'm not
saying that i'm just the atf said that
they had some illegal [ __ ]
um even though they said a lot of their
[ __ ] was legal and it was fine but
they did have a [ __ ] on of weapon
stockpiled
and that was kind of what put them on
the radar
radar so um allegedly
allegedly um branch davidian survivors
said that david koresh said that okay he
told the males
when the atf were kind of coming he's
like okay the men
um you know women and children go hide
in your rooms just like lock yourself in
there
you know they're coming and um he's like
you know the the men just get your
weapons like i've told you
and take up defensive positions now
david koresh
said um i'm gonna try to talk to the
agents
and whatever happens that's just up to
whatever the agents
end up doing so the atf arrives at 9 45
am this is february 28
of 1993 they have a whole bunch of
civilian
vehicles um a bunch of uniform personnel
in tactical gear so
at this point this is like one big point
of controversy because
nobody knows in this first initial
fire fight who shot first
um obviously uh many of the branch
davidians
say that the atf shot first the atf she
say that the british davidian shot first
there's some
stories that say that some of the atf
agents were trying to take out the guard
dogs
and that the shots from shooting the
guard dogs might have tipped
off and like that might have made people
shoot at them and blah blah blah
but whatever the story is
somebody shot somebody who was shooting
people's
dogs and they were known for that all
right that was the same thing that
happened up in
buckingham where the i forgot the name
of that damn place that
this the the what they said was a white
separatist compound
who knows what's true with what these
guys saw i mean that's just white people
up there
on their own what are you talking about
hillbillies that they never really
showed any
[ __ ] proof of anything i'm real
skeptical because whenever these dudes
get in trouble
they got to spend a narrative to cover
their asses just telling me that's the
way it is
all right um well they shout out to the
people's everyone likes to cover their
like everybody's gonna cover their asses
nobody should shoot dogs
ever because they're not yeah they shot
dude's dog and they were trying to set
him up on a sawed-off weapons
sawed-off shotgun charge that's why they
were there and they kept begging them to
[ __ ] sell them a sawed-off shotgun
dude doesn't have a [ __ ] pot to piss
in he gets a little [ __ ] hundred
dollar shotgun and [ __ ] saws it and
they [ __ ]
kill his dog and his wife it's just i i
don't i'm sorry i just don't trust at
well
well i don't either but the thing about
it is that i don't trust david crash
either because a lot of the [ __ ] that he
said was like
dude i was holding a baby and you guys
shot me it's like
the the baby that was supposedly shot in
the door
you're dealing with mass psychology as
soon as the shooting started david
creche didn't have much to do with it
everybody just started to do whatever it
is that they wanted to do well yeah
panic came in and people are going like
oh the antichrist is attacking fight
back
and i saw the videos of that day they
were [ __ ] atf climbed up on top of
that roof trying to get through that
window
and [ __ ] dr advanced branch davidians
[ __ ]
work that ass over [ __ ] up okay so
here's what happened
so um the atf agent said that they
um heard shots coming from within
the compound and like i said the branch
davidian said no the first shots came
from the atf or it came from the
helicopters because they had like three
helicopters that were going around
so like i said no one has really
definitively determined like where the
first shots
came from um it could be
as i said that the atf had shot some of
the dogs that were in the kennel
because they thought they were a threat
and then you know that was what and then
you know people started shooting because
they heard other shots
so i don't know but during the first
fire fight this is february 28th
um during the first fire fight actually
david koresh was actually wounded he was
shot in the hand and he was shot in the
stomach
now it was only like
a few minutes like a minute or two after
the whole
[ __ ] [ __ ] started started
that wayne martin who is a member of the
branch davidians he called 9-1-1
and he said you know uh he he was like
please tell them to stop shooting
um that's them shooting that's not us
that's a quote
now i should say that the first casualty
because like i said a lot of atf
agents were killed as well um
the first atf casualty was a dude
he went around to the west side of the
building and then he got wounded
now a lot of the agents started because
at this point
like it doesn't even matter who started
firing first because now everybody was
just like
firing at each other and there was like
[ __ ] bullets flying everywhere it was
like this big [ __ ]
fire fight and there was helicopters
going when they were shooting and it was
like this whole thing
now the branch davidians started
shooting at the helicopters
um none of the um pilots were killed but
the
helicopter pilots did actually land
because they were like yeah please stop
shooting at us but um so the
atf agents did kind of go around they
had a ladder they were like climbing up
they were trying to find
where the kids were and also where the
um
where the uh weapons cache was
so um they get to the west side where
koresha's
uh david crush's room was and the arm
storage
like because they knew because of you
know
like previous intel
so they get there three into and you can
see this
like if you watch the videos of the raid
because it was very well
documented they get to
um up to david crush's window and they
were
kind of crashing beside it and then like
a whole bunch of gunfire came out
one agent got killed um during this
particular
uh you know gunfire incident and then
the third
like kind of goes over the peak of the
roof and then there was like another
um like some other agents over there now
they had like some stun grenades like
some flash bangs
and they threw them in and they were
kind of trying to get into the arms room
and like get evidence of the [ __ ] before
you know i mean before i am i got hurt
so they got in there
and then when they got in there like
they started getting shot at
um another agent got killed at this
point
because he got shot in the head and then
at this point like a branch davidian
came out them
and got killed also um
and then two agents kind of like they
were having a firefight two agents got
wounded in this [ __ ] also and
then um a third agent was kind of like
helping them out
and then killed another of the cult
members
and then he kind of ran out and he fell
off the roof but he ended up living now
what ended up happening was that so okay
so this agent goes outside
he's kind of like trying to like you
know
give covering fire to the other agents
but he got killed by a cult member he
got killed
so there was just like all this kind of
[ __ ] so 45 minutes
this [ __ ] went on now
um as i said i believe as four or five
uh
atf agents got killed and some branch
davidians got killed although
all of the branch davidians um were not
killed by atf agents they were sometimes
killed by
other members of the cult who thought
that the either
because they thought they were at atf
agents or
you know for various other regions so
there was a lot of [ __ ] there was a
bunch of friendly fire incidences and
there was a fire going on
inside the [ __ ] now that was another
thing because that was another kind of
point of contention because a lot of
people said that oh well the atf started
the fire
or you know the [ __ ] that they threw in
there started the fire
now i'm not saying i don't know if i
totally blew but they said like some
the uh forensic evidence that they
examined afterwards and many years
afterward
was that it seemed like from what they
could
tell from the forensic evidence from the
you know helicopter evans who were
taking like you know uh
you know the f-f-l-i-r pictures they
were kind of like well it looked like
three fires started in three
separate places within the compound
before the tanks had breached the walls
so it does seem yeah it does seem
like the branch davidians started the
fire
yeah hernandez mentioned some [ __ ] i got
to talk about
the feds had a couple of arm a couple of
armor personnel carriers which are
they're they're a lightly armored tank
all right
they have a little turret on them but
it's not a big gun little guns
automatic guns and they can usually
carry troops i gotta remember
what it was i don't remember if it was
m113s or if it was
[ __ ] some of those other ones with
bradley i don't know if it were bradley
fighting vehicles it's been a long time
since i've seen
the video but they were running up they
they
they breached the fence that was around
the compound and they started shooting
into the compound
compound something called ferret rounds
ferret rounds are these
hollow aluminum munitions that don't
weigh much but they can punch through a
wall
and inside of them are cs gas and it's
burning so it's
it's a tear gas realm that can punch
through
civilian walls not armored walls but
civilian ones
and they're supposed to be non-lethal
you're supposed to
it's a way of pumping cs gas well they
were trying to get everyone to come
out right that's what they were trying
to do so they shot a [ __ ] ton of that in
there
now some have said that the
concentration of cs might have been
[ __ ]
high enough to spontaneously combust
because
the power had been cut already by the
feds yeah they kind of found
the the uh the branch davidians were
using like coleman lanterns
maybe it maybe there was enough cs in
there to
for the [ __ ] to catch a light but i'm
skeptical i've been in that [ __ ] it
would take a super high concentration
for it to catch on fire
and you're talking about concentrations
that would kill you
so you'd long be out of there i'm kind
of more of
like i said and i'm not forgiving the
atf or anything but i do kind of feel
like the branch davidians
um the fact that three fires started
three different locations
yeah and they did have they do have
audio of them
saying things like pour that fuel out or
whatever so it does seem like they were
trying to burn the [ __ ] down i think i
think what happened
of their own volition i think what
happened is is that there was enough cs
pumped into there that they knew they
couldn't stay
that they were going to have to
surrender so they didn't want they
didn't want to surrender they didn't
want
the flock to surrender it's time to now
go to heaven
you know uh this is looking the beast
and the antichrist and all that shit's
going down yeah
which is shitty because now it's time to
meet jesus in the [ __ ] sky
so they were saying instead of us
surrendering let's go ahead and burn the
place down and that's
and that's our way out of this we can't
surrender to the beast
and i think that's what happened i think
they used those coleman lanterns to set
the place on fire i
think they did and um turned out a lot
of the children were hiding in a little
underground compartment
yeah now the shitty thing about it it's
like people think nobody got out
it's like prior to because like i said
the siege was 51 days long you have the
raid
at the beginning of it which is what i'm
talking about right now but then after
that happened you had a raid that like
you know you had a siege that lasted 51
days so it was kind of like a standoff
like you had kind of like
do you know said they were [ __ ]
bradley fighting vehicles
you know the videos on youtube okay
because you kind of had like
the branch davidians and they were kind
of like they let some people out like
um david koresh allowed some people to
leave
um including several children but
notably he would not let any of his
own children leave um
and he released videos to the media
which showed like some of his baby mamas
and some of his other people that were
like they were like yeah we don't want
to leave
so he was kind of trying to show the
media that it's like well we just want
to stay here
and even if you guys kill us
then it's fine so
those kids could have got out because
some kids did get out
they the fbi like and the atf did allow
a bunch of because they were trying to
get all the kids out
they got some kids out and the kids that
came out
they interviewed them later and they
were like yeah the the kids that came
out like
said it was all kind of like crazy like
abuse and [ __ ] like that going on
some of them suffocated though they
didn't get out they just no i know i'm
just saying that
yeah david koresh said the rest of the
kids that are in here
they're all my kids because he had
fathered them right
with various women so there was like 12
or 14 of them and he's like we're not
leaving
so i don't know it's like really hard to
say because i do feel like there was
kind of like
later on when they did enough when they
did a kind of
you know independent investigation they
said
you know those people could have gone
out there was 51 days when the fbi just
kept
you know they kept doing [ __ ] they were
[ __ ] with them like they were
you know playing [ __ ] audio of
rabbits dying and like [ __ ] loud
music and all that kind of
you know flashing lights in their
windows and [ __ ] but they were trying
yeah they were trying to get the kids
out of there they said and they talked
to david koresh they were like
communicating with him for a very long
time
they're like look dude it's like if you
guys don't want to leave it's like at
least let the kids leave
it's like you know what are you doing
and
they were kind of getting sick of it
because david koresh was just like
he told them at first look um
the one thing that he told them was like
look let me um
go on the tv or the radio and give my
message
and then everyone can leave that's what
he told them so that people were like
oh fantastic okay so we'll do that so
they arranged it
now when they arranged it the message
that he delivered
was incoherent
he was just like a ranting about now he
had been shot
to be fair he'd been shot in his side in
his hip
so he maybe wasn't in the best state of
mind
but i've heard the tapes of that and he
just sounds like
a crazy person but they gave him
the platform they're just like okay fine
if you want to get more people into your
[ __ ]
it's like here we're giving you the
whatever so he did that
and it was kind of like a wet fart
so they're like okay well we did that
like are you gonna let the people out
now and he's just like yeah well um
okay well god told me that now i have to
wait
and they were like oh [ __ ] me so and
then he says okay well
god told me that i have to wait i have
to write this thing
he was writing this thing about the
seven
seals you know book of revelation all
that kind of [ __ ]
i have to finish writing this and then
everyone will come out
and at this point the fbi are kind of
like look
we've we've heard this [ __ ] from him
before
it's like he keeps saying oh if you let
me do this if you let me do that
like we'll let everybody out and
it never happens so they were kind of
getting pissed off about it because he
kept [ __ ] them around
so in a way like i said it's shitty what
they did but i can understand why they
did because
he just he wasn't like acting in good
faith
you know what i'm saying he kept saying
if you do this i will let the children
out
but then you would do that and then he
wouldn't do it you know what i'm saying
he had no he had he had no um plans to
give up he didn't want to go to jail
well once once the raid happened
and federal agents were actually killed
because four of them were actually
killed in the initial raid
um i think they kind of figured out
they're like well
if we do take him into custody now he'll
be
held responsible for that yeah and he
knows that
yeah so no it was a kamikaze
yeah so they're like at this point
should we even listen to anything he has
so but they did do it for like 51 days
they were just kind of like okay fine
like write your [ __ ] remember that they
were good and they let him do it and
they were just kind of sitting there and
they were waiting
and at this point so like i said it's
not like
he could he could quote a lot of
scripture he could it's it sounded good
it sounded like
he knew what he was talking about it's
just that it was his interpretation of
all this stuff and it was kind of
jumbled together into a narrative that
benefited him and the cult
you know his sanctity he was
if i remember correctly he wasn't trying
to give up
he was trying to like put a message out
to other christian sex to kind of like
rise up against the [ __ ] devil
basically because it was that's how
that's how he felt
it was a long time ago now i should say
too that like some people that were
former branch davidians like david
thibodeau who's probably like the most
famous one because
you know he wrote a book about it and
stuff and he was in there for a long
time
and he still is um
apologetic i guess toward david koresh
even though
and he still says you know we didn't
shoot first we didn't start the fires or
whatever
but he still says that it's like
look um you know our whole thing was
you know we didn't want this to happen
we didn't want
you know all of this but
i remember i mean he left so yeah i
remember people who were branch
davidians
like a couple years later doing whole
interviews on television
and they weren't ex-davidians they were
still branch the videos
well it's still around yeah they didn't
like they didn't agree with what koresh
was doing but they thought that was kind
of a fluke
kind of a one-off well like i'm saying
back to being branch divided
yeah yeah and honestly i saw a thing i
was watching a 2009 documentary about it
and the dude that was in at least in
2009 i don't know about nowadays but he
was
in control of the branch davidians he um
very stringently repudiated david koresh
and was like
look that dude said that he was jesus or
that he was going we don't
buy that it's like that's a whole other
he was really trying to like separate
himself from that
so i could see how because like we don't
believe
that a person should
you know um you know elevate themselves
to that extent
well like you say that you're jesus and
you're you say that you're the son of
god and you can do this and then the
other and god's telling you to do this
so it's like they they really really are
trying to
here's the funny sounds from that here's
the funny thing about this
had he just surrendered and gone out and
talked to the [ __ ] cops he probably
wouldn't have done any time
because uh a lot of times
cult members won't testify against each
other
well yeah because a lot of times they
can arrest them
but they can't get the charges to stick
and then the [ __ ] cult bonds them
back up that's like
that's like [ __ ] scientologists
scientologists will not
go into a court of law to testify
against another scientologist
they'll be executing excommunicated
never happened
yeah the scientologists do not see
courts
courts and governments as being above
them they see them as being below them
real evil and corrupt and
untrustworthy you know they don't ever
go to cops well that was kind of like
the situation here
yeah and like i said you know
yes and like i said the atf the fbi they
did a lot of [ __ ] wrong and they
acknowledged that
but to be fair after the raid
they did give them 51 [ __ ] days they
sat
out there and they were trying to
negotiate with this dude
um to at least get the kids that was
their main
priority they said we're just trying to
get the kids out at least we wanted
everybody out
um and a lot of times he promised hey if
you do this we'll let everybody out and
they were like awesome
do that and they set it up but he
wouldn't do it beezness said warren
jeffs is still in jail though yeah he is
that was a different situation warren
jeff's
church which is kind of like a mormon
splinter church
did [ __ ] up [ __ ] okay with kids at
least that guy did
and i don't think that was kind of like
legit even in that cult i think they did
stuff with people that were barely legal
um but anyway he did enough stuff
i think that that cult turned against
him because i think he was messing with
little boys too
and the the mormons wouldn't have
wouldn't have gone for that
they'd tell on you for that so i think
that's what happened to one jeff's if i
if i
remember correctly that was a long time
ago that [ __ ] locked up though
yeah another crazy i mean the thing
about this like i said
he was all soft though oh and here we
are and oh
he tried to be real soft and friendly
looking you seen hitler's chefs
yeah oranges yeah that was [ __ ] if
you thought he was mr rogers
i mean the shitty thing about this it's
like you know
a lot of people like to blame janet reno
and obviously she wasn't i don't think
she knew much about it
she didn't but i mean she came to bill
clinton and she was kind of like look
dude it's like these people are doing
this kind of [ __ ]
it's like and bill clinton i mean to his
credit was like look can we
deal with these people the way we do
there was like another cult
kind of standoff that had happened like
not too long before
that had they had done kind of like a um
uh you know oh my goodness i know
they had done kind of like a um you know
they they didn't engage with them
necessarily but they were just kind of
like you know [ __ ] trying to
negotiate and it ended up
fine everyone was fine no one got killed
and so bill clinton was kind of like can
we do it kind of like that and then um
you know i i would kind of prefer it to
be done like that and janet rooney was
like no no we need to go in there and do
the [ __ ] because it like i said
the he she's like look the the atf
agents have been sitting there for like
a month and a half they're kind of sick
of it
it's like they keep you know giving him
everything he wants and he won't play
ball
um because he keeps going back on it
because like i said he kept saying
hey if you do this that and the other i
will let all these people
out but then they would do that and then
he wouldn't do it
you know what i'm saying so they were
kind of like the fbi and the atf agents
were kind of like yeah we're kind of
over it
at this point so i get that um
you know it's kind of like so he's like
oh well now
all of a sudden god told me that i need
extra time because i have to write this
manuscript about
my interpretation of the seven seals and
the fbi were like okay do that
how how long is it going to take you to
do it and he's like i don't know maybe
two weeks and he's like okay fine you
have two weeks
like i heard the audio you have two
weeks
just please you know do it
and then at least let the children out
now they did get
19 children out prior to
the [ __ ] they did get 19 kids out
but the thing about it was that when it
came down to it
david koresh was not willing to all the
remaining
apparently all the remaining children
that were in the compound
were his children yeah as in once he had
fathered whether
it was 12 or 14 i can't remember but so
he was like
these are my kids and they're not
leaving so i don't know if he
just wouldn't let people leave or if
they didn't want to leave
at that point because some people did
leave okay trevor says um
excuse me straw dog says the
scientologist
they have all their cases go through
what's called religious uh
um arbitration yeah and that's weird
that's up to and including incest
rape and homicides they won't [ __ ] go
to the cops
now i don't know if it's straight up
murder but some of those
accidental homicides they'll try to
[ __ ] they'll try to cover that [ __ ]
up
like oh what's her name that they had
around the damn crazy list
remember that on the on the purification
run down killed her
who lisa mcpherson yeah mcpherson they
tried to get
up and that they killed her yeah that
was negligent homicide at least
yeah [ __ ] louis hernandez says warren
jeff's got married in prison yeah
don't they all yeah he has multiple
husbands now
okay uh titus says uh
tom get some organic honey in your tea
it coats the throat i had some organic
honey and
lemon juice in there honestly you know
what we have a house
about like right outside our
neighborhood there's a house like three
up they
they have their own hives and they sell
honey for eight dollars i think it's
eight dollars right
and that's their own beef just put the
money in the jar yeah they have like a
they have a cooler they're like just put
the money in here
and just take just take a bottle yeah so
we did that it's like on the honor
system
yeah but yeah they they have their own
like hives
yeah out there like only like a mile
away from where i live maybe
well i can't believe it we got through
the show i can't well
honestly i can't believe you did it but
honestly like i said are we done
no i don't know how much because okay
okay so
as i said you have the two
kind of factions where you know the fbi
were kind of like okay dude we're like
sick of this [ __ ] but it's like we just
want the kids out at least it's like
you know best case scenario we would
like everybody to come out that's what
they wanted
and david korash kept promising them
yeah everybody will come out if you let
me do this that and the other but then
like he kept moving the goal post so
they were getting a little
annoyed so as i said over this 50 and
like i said this was a 51 day siege if
you weren't alive in 1993
it was on the [ __ ] news every guy
i think this is the damn day every day i
think the news coverage was one of the
reasons that [ __ ] turned this into a
disaster too
because everybody was riveted to it
there's no way the feds could break
it could back down they would look weak
so they were it's like they couldn't
just
leave you couldn't just leave which
that's not done i left and come back
later
all right um when you could get him by
himself
but um no they they uh
the feds could not [ __ ] leave because
they
they had to save face strangely enough
you know they
yeah they can't show weakness well it
had gone on for so long that they're
like
we can't just leave that would
seem like an anti-climax it was i guess
it was brinksmanship
on both sides now at some point they did
consider they're like maybe we should
just snipe him
because he was the only one that they
had a um you know a warrant against
it's kind of strange though because he
wasn't facing a serious charge it's not
like he would
was a murderer or anything like that you
know what i mean they just wanted to
arrest him
yeah it's just but at when it got to
this point they were kind of like maybe
we should just shoot him and like drag
him out of this so
we can like end this so they did
consider that
um they did also consider that it would
go
like in a jonestown direction that
everyone would just like kill themselves
you knew it was going to go that way
um so they did kind of take that into
consideration before it actually
happened
and like i said at this point like
janet reno is kind of like she didn't
really i feel like she had just been
newly appointed
bill clinton was kind of like can we
just do like kind of a [ __ ] like we did
before
like where we didn't really engage and
it was kind of
and they just gave up and i kind of like
that situation better it's like
you know nobody died and that would be
better but january is like no man we've
been doing this for so long
like the [ __ ] atf agents are [ __ ]
bummed out they're so tired
it's like can we please just get in
there and end this because it's been
going on for so long
and he was kind of finally like okay
well if you think that's the right thing
to do
okay um even though that wasn't his
initial plan
so they did actually end up doing that
now
like i said a lot of people [ __ ] on
janet reno but it's like to her credit
she did actually later come out and say
you know look this is my responsibility
i [ __ ] up
it's like you know she didn't know much
about it we shouldn't have done that
right and he was a civilian
and it it did kind of feel like they
didn't take into account
a lot of you know cult experts that had
given them advice it's like please don't
you know attack them or please don't do
that kind of [ __ ] because that will just
make them double down and that will make
it
that much worse because it will be a
fire fight um
you know you won't know you don't he's
like these are people you can't reason
with like
normal people you know what i'm saying
i normally don't defend [ __ ] any of
these political party people i don't i
don't [ __ ] like them
um but in the case of janet reno she was
kind of
out of her element she was just
listening to what
paramilitary guys from the from the atf
were telling her which
you'd have if you were in her position
you would assume that they were the
experts
um i think she wanted it to be resolved
peacefully but i think they were sure
they were telling her that nobody wanted
all these people to get killed
i think they were telling her there was
no way to resolve it peacefully
which i don't think that was true either
i just would have left i would have
said okay this is a stalemate [ __ ]
you're not really wanted for any serious
crimes in terms of like murder or
anything
but we think you're messing with those
kids and if we keep hearing reports of
that [ __ ]
we're going to come back and then you
know i would have [ __ ] sent message
messages to the other branch davidians
that they would have to [ __ ]
keep that [ __ ] in check you know yeah
i kind of feel like that would have been
the best
case yeah and then i would have set up
an operation in town
and after a [ __ ] couple months six
months seven months when he relaxed his
guard he'd go into town
just [ __ ] send somebody just talk to
him [ __ ] yeah talk to him
and [ __ ] tell him it says [ __ ] you
can walk around but if we hear any more
of this [ __ ] we're picking your ass up
we're gonna charge you
and a lot of times dude like that might
go yeah maybe i should settle down
you never know well victor said um
you know or trevor said rather it's a
sunk cost fallacy that's exactly what it
is it's
i feel like at the point that the atf
and the fbi had
sunk so much um resources and so much
time
into this they had that they had to have
results we have to have something that
happens in the end or it's just going to
be a big wet fart
and i feel like that kind of worked
against them because like you said it
probably would have been better
for them to have just backed off and
said you know what we
acknowledge that you're still doing
[ __ ] up [ __ ] but we're gonna wait
until a better time
yeah a more tactical time where we can
just pick up you
and not you know kill everyone in the
whole compound because that's what it is
all this [ __ ] you know whether the um
because i do feel like the
branch davidians probably did burn their
own [ __ ] down
i don't think the atf did that but
you know that could have been avoided
there were complaints against [ __ ]
koresh but i don't think there was any
hardcore evidence not enough to get a
conviction on him
i think there was just complaints
against him and you got to have
witnesses willing to testify and all
kind and they were all inside the damn
compound yeah i don't think they were i
think with other people who were loosely
connected to the cult
well people who had left left sure right
well
that's not real good in a court of law
you could say they're disgruntled and
they're making [ __ ] up
and [ __ ] then they hop then they haul
the girls out and go oh no
karesh never touched me they they're
going to do that that's what well and
that's kind of what they do that's what
scientologists do
they cover for each other because they
all keep it in-house so
oh look just saying ex-military i'm
telling the ex-infantry
they shouldn't that was a [ __ ] dumb
ass raid dumb
but it was they probably should have i
mean they didn't know they
they just they bet on they bet
on the possibility that the branch of
davidians would not put up a
a spirited defense of the compound
trevor [ __ ] went down [ __ ]
in a blaze of glory [ __ ] they went to
valhalla well
after it went to a certain point i kind
of feel like they were like yeah we're
just going to burn it all down
yeah because trevor said wasn't there
auto like audio from inside the compound
of them saying grab the fuel yes there
was
yeah and um there was some audio
that they played at one of the because
they did like a [ __ ] hearing later on
especially after the oklahoma city
bombing which timothy mcveigh
which happened in 1985 and that was
timothy said that i'm doing this on the
anniversary of
the week ago because that was kind of
like that inspired like a lot of [ __ ]
later on a lot of terrorist
[ __ ] later on yeah and so like the fact
that he did that
made them reopen an investigation
so they kind of went back into it now
they did go into
like i said there was audio um because
they had the
um compound bugged
and they did have some audio that
sounded very much like people saying
like where's the fuel or like pour it
out or like david said to pour it out or
like things like that so
and like i said they had like the um the
infrared [ __ ] from the helicopters like
the camera [ __ ]
and they saw like fire starting you know
in three separate places
at the same time before before
the you know the atf or the fbi had
um come through the walls so
i feel like a lot of the [ __ ] that the
cult people said about oh
the atf started the fires i think that's
probably [ __ ]
um because i think they started that
[ __ ] i don't i'm not saying that all the
atf memphis like they don't know
like what the other dtf members are
doing
but i don't think the atf did the fires
i don't think they did either
it's more in line than what the branch
davidians did it they they [ __ ]
wanted to uh save basically save their
purity that there's no way that they're
gonna
side with the [ __ ] antichrist well
yeah they kind of had the mindset
of well this is armageddon yeah this is
that we've been talking about this
we would rather die than be taken alive
we're not going to [ __ ] yield to the
forces to say right
i was just look they it's not just me
saying that they shouldn't have done it
now the atf will tell you that they
shouldn't have done it so it's not just
me
um what they should have done is backed
off and [ __ ]
let everything chill back out and then
come back a little bit later and talk to
them
yeah they you have to [ __ ] they
acknowledge that that was a mistake
you have to understand something you're
going to say well we got to stop all
this child abuse so what we're going to
do is we're going to kill all these kids
no that's not how you solve the [ __ ]
yeah that's not what they intended
though they didn't but that's not
what happened and you would have should
have known that that's what would have
happened
uh because that's usually how it goes
down with other [ __ ] real
zealot cults um it would be just as
i know what they were thinking it was a
small kind of ass
backwards looking compound all right of
that didn't have a whole lot of money
they thought they could put on a show
and score a quick pr victory
that's exactly that's what they think i
don't think that they thought
that these were true believers that
would fight to the death
for what they believed in they weren't
prepared for what they're trying to save
they're trying to save this so-called
child abuse on these little kids
well if that's the case then why don't
you [ __ ] take down scientology
because that's going on in scientology
and there's a lot more of them well
i think there's a lot more science why
because scientology is [ __ ] scary
it's got a lot of money it's got an army
of [ __ ] lawyers
they sue the [ __ ] out of you they
brought the [ __ ] they brought the fbi
to its knees
okay not the fbi uh yeah they they
brought the fbi to the irs
and the irs they infiltrated the fbi and
something called operation snow white
and then they [ __ ]
they harassed the irs into giving them
tax-free status it's only wrong when
you're too weak to back it up
all right [ __ ] if you're as powerful
as scientology was back in those days
you could make any wrong a right
that's what kind that's the thinking
they just send an army of lawyers and
pis against you and just wither the [ __ ]
out of you
and they don't attack government uh
institutions they attack people that
work in those government institutions
and
and and break them down through
private eyes because they understand
that's a more effective
tactic because you can go after one
person one person
or effectively then you can go after an
entire yeah why are you want to attack a
government
[ __ ] institution you know who works
there and their names you know their
families you got private eyes
you go after them that way if you cross
scientology they [ __ ] got you
so atf wasn't going to raid scientology
what are they going to do if we're going
to raid they would go up there [ __ ]
at the rim of the world what was that
[ __ ] base that they had up there
gold base up in the [ __ ] mountains
and [ __ ]
i i think i think [ __ ] scientology
would put up a spirited defense
it wouldn't be worth it they'd go down
fighting
well yeah and i think that's kind of the
tragedy of waco
is that as much as you know they might
have had
justification for going in there it's
like i don't really think that they
realized
what they were up against um as far as
you know they knew that they were armed
to the teeth but i don't think they
really
understood that these people were
willing to die for what they believed
and that this was what they were
expecting
yeah they were expecting you know
someone to come after that was like
playing right into their narrative hold
on i gotta fix some [ __ ] here
yeah to mark yeah operation snow white
you go ahead and you look that up
operation snow white was the largest
infiltration of the [ __ ] fbi in
[ __ ] history
scientology infiltrated the fbi and
there was like lots of them in there
and it was because l ron hubbard wanted
to know exactly what the fbi knew about
him
they they were going in there erasing
files on scientology
they were [ __ ] scientology no [ __ ]
well back in the old days
back in those days you could just kind
of apply for a job and it's like no i'm
totally not a scientologist and you
could just like get a job in a
higher master of nun says how powerful
is scientology now
and victor garcia says about about as
strong as a small pony
i still wouldn't cross scientology too
badly because they'll do they'll fair
game you
they'll send i mean if you're just like
one person yeah i wouldn't
recommend it i wouldn't recommend it
because they can [ __ ] up your life
yeah if you're in a larger
uh you know institution or a larger
group you're probably all right because
yeah it's gonna pay attention they're
not as they're not they're not as rough
as they were
right because they realize there's no
way to discredit a
person's anymore there's no way to
silence people anymore because most of
the rules of scientology were written
pre-internet and they were never really
able to cope with the power well the
[ __ ] about it too
is that a lot of the stuff that they
would because if you are
um if you come on their radar um
criticizing them
to a great enough degree they will build
a um a hate website against you
that will accuse you of whatever they
think they can get away do it on myspace
yeah which they're real backwards on the
internet they are
uh that's that's another thing but
they'll kind of accuse you of
oh they're gay or they're they say no
that [ __ ] works anymore it's [ __ ] that
like people don't care
about well they'll say you're a child
molester though they'll come yeah child
molester is their
thing nowadays because they know that
that's kind of like
something that actually gets people's
lives i'll recommend two shows for you
one of them's on youtube called
surviving
scientology it's hosted by karen de la
carriere who was
she was married to like the number two
and number three guy in scientology for
many years and
he disappeared didn't he yeah they got
him [ __ ] locked up in scientology
do we know where he is and his son her
son
he died right yeah under suspicious
under suspicious circumstances right so
surviving scientology there's a lot of
good interviews with people that knew
lrh
and it's on youtube uh and it's really
informal it's just an old podcast
and there's [ __ ] all kinds of badass
stories of what happened
in on these scientology bases and
[ __ ] how how people were punished and
how lrh
[ __ ] um [ __ ] did [ __ ] and how that
why they built secret bases you just
gotta check it out uh another one would
be leah remini's show on
netflix that was called what the
remedy show on netflix is what's the
name of that show do you remember um
yeah what is that yeah it's got mike
render and leah remini
and if you just look up scientology on
netflix you'll see it's a really good
series
but um yeah it's three seasons yeah
people
regular people do not understand the
power of two things
one corporations
two cults they don't understand them
because
they're armies basically they're
basically armies they have some of them
have their own justice systems
well they set it up for that reason yeah
totally self defensive [ __ ]
freestanding
government that does its own thing it's
kind of an enemy of the
of the nation that it's in they they
don't like the nation that it's in those
people are sinners yeah scientology and
the aftermath that's what it's called
is that what it's called scientology
yeah it's called scientology
something something like that take it or
whatever t you and your husband need to
go on [ __ ] youtube and go
and look for surviving scientology with
[ __ ]
karen dela carrier her husband doesn't
uh he he does a lot of the uh
they're [ __ ] wild now they're
ex-scientologists they're [ __ ]
crazy but they'll tell all kinds of
stories it smells kind of crazy they're
still kind of crazy
but you can go back to like four or five
years ago that
of the of what they were posted and that
was like the really good [ __ ] when it
was new
and when people were first kind of
escape high level people were escaping
the cult
and telling the stories and how
scientology was built
it's an amazing construction jenny
laughs at it i laugh that it's dumb as
[ __ ] but that [ __ ]
is a working system that in the time
that it was engineered
was was very terrifying well like i said
in a way
it's kind of like that's that's one of
the things that makes me laugh
about it because i can't believe that
people are so [ __ ] dumb is to like
fall for that kind of [ __ ] well they're
being born in it now
but but yeah like i'm not [ __ ] on
people that were born in it because like
you don't know any better
like but and it has
cults in general are fascinating to me
for that very reason scientology has
this corporate
it used to have a very corporate upper
middle class just
white bread image to it
snow white something that was just like
above reproach totally moral that's kind
of what it looked like and it was a
corporation
as a corporation of salvation and it had
it would eventually it would sell you
courses and programs
and then it would walk you up a bridge
through a bunch of training programs to
make a [ __ ] a wizard or a jedi
all right and they're doing things to
your mind
that look a lot like something out of
1984 like some kind of damn communist
brainwashing
thing it's a it's a it's a
a ufo cult that
does inquisition of its members on a lie
detector test
on basically a lie detector to
exercise demonic alien spirits from your
soul
that's some wild [ __ ] and you're
fighting for them that's not what
they're calling it
that's what it they're doing they have
other [ __ ] terminology for it but i
was just doing it and i was like that's
[ __ ] genius
that's [ __ ] genuine well all cults
yeah operate
essentially the same way yeah um
they just have different terminology
yeah it's all the same
thing though um what you're basically
doing
you're trying to one you're trying to go
after
vulnerable people that's kind of your
year one thing
two you're trying to isolate people from
people who might be like hey man this is
[ __ ] you don't want any of that so
it's like well you can't talk to your
family anymore you can't do this that
because they're
unbelievers or they're or if you're a
scientology oh they're wogs that's what
they call them
so it's like you're trying to try to
isolate that person so you're trying to
you know um you know the people in the
cult are your family now
so you're not getting any outside
influence um
cutting you off from the internet
cutting you off from
outside influence that's a really really
big thing that a lot of cults do because
they don't want you
questioning anything anything about
anything that you're being told
survivors all cults were the same way
yeah but what's funny is that all cults
work the same way but you start seeing
it in militaries and corporations and
you see it in [ __ ] sales tactics
wow a lot of [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] that
corporations and political
groups do go and read or listen to an
audio book by a dude named robert l
shook he was the master of hardball
sales techniques
and it's how to convince somebody
to do something for you without them
even
knowing that you did it
i used to do it all the time as a
[ __ ] salesman all right it's called
hardball
and it's just asking a series of
questions and you know which way
the person's gonna fall and no matter
which way they fall you know the next
question
to funnel them down logically you're
using their logic against them
into the end result of signing on that
goddamn dot
blind that's what you're trying to get
them to do and it works a lot
well as i said it's all the same because
it's all about the same and that's what
cults do and
and they're all doing it television is
doing it [ __ ] all these
the thing about colts is companies are
doing it to you a lot of them i don't
even know if they go into it
with this kind of um i don't think they
plan it all ahead of time
they just kind of come to that as a
natural thing because as i said humans
you know we're very predictable in a lot
of ways like our brains work in
predictable ways yeah it's
like a flow chart yes so it's like if
you can
tap into that yeah you can get most but
not everybody obviously but you can get
like a large
okay i'm gonna counter what some of the
[ __ ] that you said i noticed
that the higher the education level the
higher the income level
the higher the success rate and it's
because rich people don't have defenses
for it
working class people and [ __ ] poor
people have a much higher
harder life and have a much bigger
resistance to it so you have to use a
different technique which is
more of a fantasy and salvation line
that'll work too
believing in the unseen well you have to
go about it different things
because the thing about it is that
working class people are people who
don't have a lot of money which like i
said coming out they don't have money
anyway
well because like i don't have any money
so i'm coming at it from that point of
view
so it's kind of like you really have to
get past people like that's defenses
because
you already have that thing where i'm
just like look i'm not going to spend
money on this because i don't have it
and it seems like a waste
victor victor says it sounds kind of
like
q anon i said that a couple weeks back
i analyzed the q anon phenomenon
and knowing how religions work how they
started and everything q anon was
a lot like a roman mystery religion
you had an oracle priests that were
[ __ ]
deciphering or interpreting what the
oracle said
a battle between good and evil uh
the emperor uh trying to save the land
and the emperor being a a minor deity
um and it's not going to go away
now you're going to have the return of
the king narrative and this is all
happening in
an imaginary world beyond what's visible
almost like the spirit realm
and here's the thing don't get all
snotty because i think most of these
religions come from situations like that
it's desperate people with a lot of
[ __ ] imagination with democracy
well they're trying to make sense out of
[ __ ] that they don't like
or that they don't believe in so and
and and i can understand how somebody
could fall into that into a bunch of
rumors you know what was rumors
i know all right all right jenny jenny
is
jenny is ex-generation so am i okay
a lot of the people that kind of fell
into that came from
an air boomers were boomers and and
where
their version of reality was painted out
to them on television no
because there were some young people
that fell into that should you but i
don't know what y'all's excuse
was uh actually i i detected by
listening to those people that it was
larping
they're just having fun with it i think
a lot of it
i think a lot of it was just larping and
having fun
and like you know live action role
playing and [ __ ]
is like anything else that you you have
people that want to be in an
important movement just like a cult it's
exactly like that
well yeah well that's what it is and i
don't think
i think a good number of them did not
believe it the thing about it
is that i think there is a subset of
people and like i said it's not
necessarily intelligence that's that's a
different
issue i think there's can i talk
yeah you talk but i was gonna say
something never mind i'm going to that
one i'll go to the bathroom okay because
evidently i can't no no no no she's been
drinking [ __ ] okay
no i was trying to say
that a lot of the [ __ ] that i heard
those guys saying
for that q and on thing i don't think
they believed it i think that
it's kind of like role playing
kind of in the same way when i was in
military academy you had people who
pretended to be real christian they
weren't real christian they just
pretended to be that way that was just a
way of
[ __ ] getting attention and [ __ ]
look at me that's what i think it was
i think a lot of it was that and it was
a way of [ __ ] driving other people
they're like oh you don't believe it i'm
gonna [ __ ] triple down on it i'm
gonna
quadruple down on it and then it starts
getting more and more ridiculous
they don't believe it they're [ __ ]
with you that's what i think a lot of
that was
because some of that [ __ ] was just so
[ __ ] ridiculous
as is it was just a way of [ __ ] with
people i don't know maybe in the comment
section would agree with me or not but
that's what i think it was
yeah it's a unique cult it's kind of
like a crowd source online conspiracy
theory it's exactly what it was
i think it was kind of a it was
it was what you would see in [ __ ]
the early roman empire with the [ __ ]
all these uh mystery
religions coming up and it was all just
based on rumors
but now it happens a lot faster because
you have internet back in those days
a cult was kind of like merged with
theater and uh
and what do you call it a theater and
[ __ ] a nightclub
so it it's it's like ancient [ __ ] it's
just it's happening faster now go ahead
you done oh yeah i'm done can i talk now
i've like forgot what i was going to say
because we got to finish the show
well i guess what i had to say wasn't
important
[Laughter]
why you know stop it that's how you do
i'll talk tomorrow i'm drunk yeah so am
i
but you know how far along were we on
this
i don't know hour and 20 minutes
but i can't believe that this stream
held out as long as it did
well let's see
still says excellent still says
excellent all right we must have had
some kind of
weird well [ __ ] happens it's not always
a conspiracy
i know how i know how you do but it's
not always a conspiracy
because we've been streaming several
times a week without a problem
so yeah when every now and then we have
a problem
it doesn't mean that somebody is
okay you know trying to silence us or
whatever
i'm just saying it's it's just not that
um you know so all right i don't even
know how long the show is
going on i think i think you're right
there after uh
a jury trial lasting nearly two months i
think that's where you were yeah i know
well i was gonna say some other [ __ ] but
i forgot now because
you just interrupted and i had to go to
the bathroom so i i'm not allowed to
talk evidently look at this in this [ __ ]
i'm not one of those
okay well i was gonna say something i
was gonna it was gonna forget it if i
didn't say it i was trying to [ __ ]
rap
well have you ever thought that maybe
that happens with me also no no
and then i forget and then i can't
remember because you yapped and then i
had to
i was just like you know what [ __ ] it
and i just went to the bathroom 13
o'clock has been deemed unsafe and it's
the potential to incite a riot
yeah didn't get me started on those
retards yeah the stream was picking up
negative non-thinking vibe
[Laughter]
don't get me started on those retards
jerry says she's injured i won't hurt
anyone's feelings
but um you know so tom and jenny you're
spreading misinformation this is all
[ __ ] funny [ __ ]
okay so all right so i don't even
remember what i was going to say but
[ __ ] i'm just going back to the way
because i was going to say something
cool but
i i guess it's not important um so
anyway
some of the branch davidians and like i
said this is another thing that kind of
pisses me off because all these like
branches like oh persecution blah blah
blah
but they got brought into trial and
they were charged with various things
like including like
you know not necessarily first degree
murder obviously but like colluding like
conspiracy and the murder of these some
of the
agents and pretty much uh
most of them got acquitted um you know
so they
got off with it now um
so i think that like there were like 12
of them that survived and they kind of
went to
court but a lot of them like they didn't
really face any
severe charges some of them some of them
did but
they were out by july of 2007.
now after that like a bunch of the
branch davidians they tried to sue
they tried to do like civil uh you know
suits against
you know the government against the
governor of texas against
various other agencies and basically
um all of those suits were overturned
because they couldn't really find enough
evidence to say
that you know anyone had like you know
that any of their suits had any like
merit to them
so um all of that [ __ ] was uh rejected
so basically as i said after the
oklahoma
bombing which happened in 1995. and as i
said timothy mcveigh
we might do a whole show about that one
of these days i'm not promising anything
but he did do um he did say that
his main impetus for this act of
terrorism which killed
i believe 168 people uh
was to do with because he thought like
the government was overreaching on the
wakeup thing or whatever so that was
kind of one of his motivations for doing
the [ __ ]
so after that happened uh the federal
government said well we need to look
back into the [ __ ] we're gonna
reopen the investigation on the waco you
know
[ __ ] they didn't call it that but
i'm calling it that
so just to see like what we can see
about it
now so they bring in like a special
investigator for it
and among the um
allegations were as i mentioned earlier
that it was the federal agents that
started the fires
inside of the compound which as i said
they
you know and as i said take this however
you want to take it but they did do
a lot of outside research they had a lot
of you know arson investigators and all
that stuff and they're like look it
looks like
the fires were started inside they're
not saying that
they were started on purpose they're
just saying that the fires were started
inside the compound
before the compound was breached so
it looks like the branch davidians
started the fires
whether accidentally on purpose they
weren't making a judgment about that
they're just saying that it looks like
that's what happened
and it looks like too that a lot of the
[ __ ]
because the thing about it david koresh
and this was
um another thing that made one of the
followers call him a coward
was that when they finally found that
douche's body
um he had died of a gunshot wound
so either he died he killed himself or
had his second in command
kill him because he thought that it
would be easier than dying in the fire
um which a lot which a lot of
um his followers that survived or had
escaped earlier
thought like i said that made him a
coward because they're like oh you were
very willing to let all of your
followers
you know burn up but you didn't want to
suffer in that way
so you just shot yourself or like it was
kind of like a jim jones kind of
situation so a lot of people are like
pissed off about it
and like i said there are still branch
davidians nowadays like that [ __ ]
compound and mount carmel is not really
there anymore you can still visit the
site as far as i know
um but it's kind of like it's all burned
out and it's there's just kind of like a
little memorial with like
graves with all the people's names that
died on them and stuff
but um a lot of the ex
members um have said that
they really i don't know it's it's
really difficult because some of the ex
members are kind of like
yeah i'm not like a big fan of david
koresh because it seems like he went out
like a [ __ ]
but you know they they're not forgiving
the atf either because it's like yeah
they just came in there and they didn't
really need to
but i don't know it just
this this case is really like [ __ ]
[ __ ] with me because there's like a
lot of
back and forth i'm not really sure whose
side i'm on i'm not sure if i'm on
anyone's side
in this [ __ ] because other than you know
on the kids side yeah the kids side
that's about the kids and the dogs
that's the only people i care about in
this situation
it's like everybody that was an adult
and chose not to leave because honestly
some of the independent
um [ __ ] that they did later on they're
like look even once the fire started
people in the compound like the fbi and
everything were like hey you can leave
it's like you know it's fine we're out
here
it'll be we're not gonna shoot you or
anything like that we don't hurt you
they could have left and they did not
they chose not to so i do kind of feel
like
there comes a point where if a person is
an adult
and they're telling you look this is
like a bad situation this is like a bad
cult where you know we can help you just
get out of there
and they chose not to and they chose not
to
it seems like david koresh wanted to
keep his own children
who he had fathered which was like 14 of
them apparently
he wanted to keep him in there he
wouldn't let them leave along with their
mothers
and the videos that he released seemed
to show the mothers of these children be
like yeah i don't want to leave
let the kids out i don't care about the
grown-ups let the kids out and let the
dogs out
i don't give a [ __ ] about the grown-ups
if you want to like [ __ ] if that's
what you want to do with your life
and you really believe that the end of
the world is coming and it's like yeah
you want to die in this big
conflagration rather than coming out
which
probably could have um i kind of feel
like you're an adult so that's on you
you know what i'm saying i don't know
it's it's really hard because probably
you're brainwashed but
this is what i'm saying this is what and
we talked about this a little bit on the
last show
the um the heavens gate one it's like
i'm really conflicted about cult
[ __ ] and we might get into this a little
bit tomorrow too because
um i want to talk about that surviving
death show we're talking about like
mediums and all that kind of [ __ ] that
they do
i kind of feel like there's a really
hard there's a very very
um you know it's just not a clear line
if you're a grown-up between
if you're doing something that's like
harmful to yourself or harmful to others
and it's like
at which point should people in your
family or people who love you
intervene and stop you from doing that
[ __ ]
you know what i mean it's really hard to
get to that point like when somebody is
a grown-up
if it's a kid it's easy get them the
[ __ ] out of there i get that
but if you're like you know if you're
like 20 30 years old and you
ostensibly should know better at what
point can you come in there
and say yeah you don't even know what
the [ __ ] you're doing i need to get you
get you the [ __ ] out of here you know
what i'm saying well it's just like they
wanted to raid scientology
to get everybody out of the hole they
got [ __ ]
dozens of scientologists in this place
called the hole that's what i'm saying
it's a couple of trailers put up to
each other [ __ ] bars all over the
windows
and some of them have been in there for
about a decade all right they're eating
and they won't leave
and they won't leave they will leave you
raided that place and said
come on out of there you're free they'd
be like no no no no it's my religious
duty to be here
they're [ __ ] and i feel like that's
kind of what happened in this situation
because
i mean as shitty as what the atf and the
fbi did and i'm not saying that
like what they did was shitty they
[ __ ] it up they shouldn't have gone
about it that way
but they did give those people every
opportunity look
please come out we want you to come out
they wanted everybody to come out they
didn't want anybody to die
and i feel like those people would not
come
out and at what point can you just like
say [ __ ] it
we can't help you anymore is the isn't
the hole in riverside
i want to get it over now that's where
they had all the damn
psyops music and then putting all the
[ __ ] sprinklers on the protesters
i think that was the riverside it might
have been they were trying to look for
leah
they were trying to look for uh david
miscavige shelley miscavige shelly
misguided they're trying to look for
[ __ ] do we know where she is
no no i think she's at the rim of the
worth of well that's what they
said i think she's up at gold based
doing paper i think they killed her i
don't think she's in the hole
i think they can't yeah i don't think
they did they've killed other people
he just alleged i don't think he killed
her i think he's got it
he's got her work in a mundane job up
there at the [ __ ] gold base [ __ ]
under lock and key where nobody can see
see this guy this is just so conflicting
because
he's doing those damn stats you had to
do yeah yeah how many
are you are you upstat you've been in
here for [ __ ] 20 years are you upset
oh my god damn right you got to be
upstate every day so your stats should
be to the moon by now
yeah that's what i mean i'm like when
are you guys going to say that it's like
it it can't go on infinitely no it's how
long am i going to work here like
if i can even work their year and i'm
like you know what [ __ ] you guys i'm
leaving
i couldn't even take it but that's why
i think that's why cults fascinate me so
much is because
like i said if it's a different
situation if you're born into it and
it's like you don't
know any better that's all you're taught
i mean obviously you should
you know someone should get you the [ __ ]
out of there as soon as possible
but if you join when you're an adult
whether it's scientology
whether it's this [ __ ] whether it's
whatever it is
um at what point do we say
that you are no longer in control of
your faculties and we need to come in
there
and just get you out for your own
well-being
at what point do we do that it's just
not gonna happen
i mean there there has to be a point
right you would think
no belief is very powerful and can
and but believing in things can get you
killed
well obviously because that's what
happened in this yeah
this should be they stayed they could
have left
and they didn't this should be a good
example and they stayed in there with
their children
who they could have let out but they did
not it should be a good example of not
don't believe everything
there are beliefs don't believe anything
that make a lot of sense on the surface
but then as you go into it and get
deeper and deeper into it
you're believing in things that aren't
true and can eventually threaten your
life
i mean this [ __ ] should have been a red
flag from the beginning because this
shit's like crazy but if you were to
pull them out of there they'd go right
back in there they would say it was
their religious freedom it would be just
like [ __ ] scientology
and it's kind of like somebody who has a
[ __ ]
some kind of uh you see i'm not trying
to help people in the same way you are
because i know it's not possible
sometimes they have a mind virus that
can't really be
well yeah but that's that's what
fascinates me about it is that at what
point
like are those people not even control
of their same
of their actions anymore yeah that's not
on you they need to just get the
children out of there is what i would do
well yeah there's obviously there's this
slippery slope
with oh well if you don't like this
religion then you take these people's
children
you know there are a lot of good
religions out there and if you turn on
that you know i don't like buddhism [ __ ]
these buddhists they're crazy
yeah if they're not doing anything
illegal to have children it has to be
something that child protective services
can't deal with
that's what i mean if it gets to a point
like i said you can teach
i don't agree with it and i'm not a big
fan
of you know you can teach your kids
whatever [ __ ] you want to teach them
you can do what you want to to a point
but if it gets to a point
where one you are abusing those children
or you're going to kill the children or
you're yeah that's good because there's
a lot of done that because it's like oh
we're going to do an exorcism and then
they [ __ ] smile
you just drown them in a swimming pool
for a [ __ ] right right they're just
obeying the father
some kind of [ __ ] like that or if you're
doing [ __ ] where it's like
i don't know there there's a just a fine
line between
because a kid can't choose a kid can't
choose
if you're in a grown-up and you want to
join like a stupid cult
okay i'm not gonna stop you yeah
i mean um i'll stop you if it gets to a
point where you're like hurting other
people that aren't involved in your
[ __ ]
okay but a kid that's different
because they can't pick you know what i
mean so
i kind of feel like you know
as much as i don't want to excuse the
fbi or the atf in this situation
at least they have the right priorities
they're like look we just want to get
the kids out of there we don't give a
[ __ ] what you guys want to do if you
guys want to stay that's fine
but please just let the kids come out
and they did get some of the kids out i
think they got 19 kids out
and they did say they were being abused
and [ __ ] but the kids that were
ostensibly david koresh's kids he would
not let them leave
yeah now you know okay uh they're saying
that
gold base is in in riverside yeah gold
base i believe
is where the hole is but i don't think
that's where um
shelly miss cabbage is she's at another
place it's a secret
base up in the ceiling she's dead i
don't think so she's up there
in a secret base in the sierra nevada
mountains they call it i think
they call it the rim of the world i
think that's the the i think that's the
the scientology slang word for it but i
don't remember
the name of that base do you it's not
gold base
um it's all on that surviving
scientology man you'll hear it there are
people that live
[ __ ] lived and worked in some of
these bases for like 20 years they'll
tell you everything that happened there
and just the [ __ ] about
this bizarre scientology is that like i
said
i didn't know a lot about like i'd heard
about it because i saw the dinette
commercials and whatnot like in the 80s
but when i started working there when i
lived in
uh clearwater in the you know early
2000s
it's like it seems like [ __ ]
if you don't know anything about it like
if you start reading about it it sounds
like that can't be real
it is though like all the [ __ ] that they
do
it's totally real another thing that's
[ __ ] bizarre that a lot of people
don't know about is that scientology
has a secret base out in the desert that
looks like a maximum security prison
it's just a big [ __ ] concrete wall
that goes around it
it's got barbed wire on the top
and it has an underground vault with all
of lrh's elrond hubbard's [ __ ] sacred
writings
on these big [ __ ] in these big
[ __ ] hermetically sealed plastic
[ __ ] containers and they're all
[ __ ] laser imprinted on titanium
plates because wouldn't you love it if
the earth got wiped out and that was all
the only thing that will survive is that
is that [ __ ] right there so
and here's the [ __ ] weird thing they
always got i think it was i think they
said it's always got two guys
serving there and some of them [ __ ]
like life
sentences they're [ __ ] watching that
[ __ ] and they commit suicide a lot
evidently
i don't blame them yeah they got they
got [ __ ] uh
and stuff and cameras everywhere motion
detectors they can see you coming for
for miles away it's like something out
of it out of the [ __ ] 80s horror
flick an 80s sci-fi flick can you
imagine
what was that 80s or flick about the
[ __ ] guy lee majors and he stole the
car
he stole the [ __ ] car it was in a it
was in the future
and gasoline was the final
conflict remember that gasoline was
[ __ ]
illegal everybody had these electric
cars and lee majors was a race car
driver
and burgess meredith was a fighter pilot
and they have a very final battle where
they send the [ __ ] jet to go [ __ ]
stop the car
so it doesn't make it to the free zone
it's just like i think i think [ __ ]
scientologists saw that movie
because there's a lot of stuff that
looks like something out of that damn
base
out in [ __ ] out the desert it just needs
like laser turrets that's the only thing
it needs
well they got a lot of ideas from movies
yeah i think they got a lot of ideas for
movies
i mean [ __ ] like that this is what bums
me out about it
because i always think to myself you
have
wasted your entire life
doing that [ __ ] yeah you've wasted your
entire life
thinking that xenu was real and that you
regarding like elrond hybrid [ __ ] like
for some
like what the last chase that's what it
was called he remembers it
oh yeah yeah yeah that was on mst
actually yeah the last chase that was on
the very
first like the yeah ktma like i liked it
when i was a kid you look at it now
it's just [ __ ] terrible yeah that was
on the [ __ ]
local tv season
of msd like before we even went national
it was not as it was
it was it was worse than damnation alley
and the damnation alley was pretty bad i
mean
the last like i saw it because i saw
some of the ktma uh
mst episodes so i thought i missed you
but
um i don't even remember what happened
to it yeah so it couldn't have been that
good
no if you know what i mean so like i
said i think that's what bums me out
about the cult [ __ ]
is that it occurs to me
and especially like when we're watching
the [ __ ] about scientology or when i'm
watching
[ __ ] about you know the branch davidians
or whatever
it's like some of these people have been
in it for
30 or 40 years and i'm like
how does it feel to have wasted
30 or 40 years of your entire life
believing that crap how does that feel
no you're you're
when you know because it the scientology
show like someone realizes
yeah and then like getting out of it
like 35 40 years later i'm like what
does that feel like it must feel like
your entire life has been a total waste
the branch davidians went that's how i
would the branch davidians didn't i
don't think they went through that
because they they went right back to
just being well they just changed to
another type of christian denomination
they did but like i said there's still
well
there's not that many of them left um it
should be said that
like that compound the mount carmel
compound is gone
um there's a memorial there but that's
about it there are still a few
branch davidians but not too many
obviously because
of the bad press um but the ones that
are left
uh vehemently uh denounce
david koresh they're just like look
nobody no human
can say that they're jesus or their god
or you can put yourself on the same
level so they think that was like
sacrilegious they call him like satan
and stuff so they're kind of like trying
to distance themselves
which as i said i can understand that
but still
get the [ __ ] out of there because it's
it's a cult man it's
it's it's not good well we're coming up
on 10 o'clock and i think we've pretty
much covered the show huh
probably i don't know even if we did
yeah
yeah it ended right i don't know yeah
i don't know all right then we'll uh it
was good that you guys [ __ ]
uh came to see us i can uh you sent us
some of them flash bulbs that's [ __ ]
fantastic
sorry for the technical difficulties
that we had earlier yeah that was really
frustrating for some reason the stream
got solid
um i think it might have been our
provider maybe having problems i don't
know i think that's probably what it was
uh but it's come back
hopefully we don't have this same
problem we stream tomorrow yes yeah we
change tomorrow
tomorrow we're going to talk about that
surviving death
okay yeah yeah that's right yeah so
we're going to talk about like life
after death tomorrow
yeah if you guys want to see something
like i said i got i got a lot of
uh thoughts about that yeah
only the first episode is worth watching
but uh that's the new death experience
got a little [ __ ] after you got real
[ __ ] [ __ ] well
not a little [ __ ] you're liable but
i'm just
other than that um what else is going on
victor says mark's safe from the david
koresh episode yeah
and sophie said that uh next wednesday i
gotta save the stories about
glendale because you got to talk about
the glenn daniels that's amazing stories
but because um so flex glenn lansing
i sent her i sent her i like glenn
danzig's music yes
i don't want to hang out with the dude
because he seems like he'd be a giant
[ __ ]
douche nozzle that's a douche nozzle but
yeah but she listens to the [ __ ]
misfits and
uh i don't know if she's listening to
sam main or sawing silent yeah
she's trying songs sounds better yeah
sam mains actually better than misfits i
think
i like it better i don't know if i could
well you could tell that metal was going
to start coming into it
i'm not a big metal fan so maybe that's
why oh man that first glen dancing album
came out this [ __ ] was [ __ ] awesome
well i was
i have a soft spot for the misfits
because my
brother learned to play guitar it is
punk band
by listening to the misfits and also bad
religion so it's like he'd always
because his bedroom was next to my
adventure so i always hear like his
guitar
practice like coming through my wall
yeah and we listened to like a lot of
the same music at the time
so that i don't know that it's like
nostalgic i gotta i'm mark it's in bad
religion
mark i got a goth priest outfit yeah i
got it you do
yeah yeah it's all bondage and [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's like this big long it
goes all the way down
should i say a dress it's almost like a
cast it's a it's like a dress it's a
cassock
yeah and it has like a priest frock yeah
and it has like [ __ ]
yeah uh you know straps that go across
like that
it's nice okay well
yeah try try sam sam means like in
between
misfits and and um
and danzig it's like right in between
mark says you should wear it
for the wednesday show yeah or maybe for
the tomorrow show
we'll see you know what we should do
since we're talking about
the surviving death [ __ ] on netflix
we should try and contact some spirits
on tomorrow
it would be the spirits you were
thinking of though depending on what i
eat
well i yeah you know i'm prepared for
yeah i'm well aware of those spirits
like i said i don't have a ouija board
but look
i have a um i have a mouse pad
a mouse pad it looks like a ouija board
we could use that actually we could do a
whole [ __ ] sound
because i'm saying like what okay
this is a teaser now the first episode
decent that was about near-death
experiences okay
yeah it lines up with a lot of the
near-death experience the two out of
body and the
near-death experience i had it's a lot
like that and they had a lot of doctors
and people [ __ ] talk about it yeah so
that's good witnesses like i said i'm
not
okay so like i said that's fine but the
next
two they spent two whole episodes which
are almost an hour long
talk about medium on modern day mediums
and i feel like
the mediums that's been played out i was
like dude this is like two hours of
people going
i feel like yeah and i'm just like oh my
god
yeah women trying to sound like little
boys and then kill me
women trying to sound like old man yeah
it's like look i'm gonna i'm doing a
seance and i'm gonna go in this box but
you're not allowed to film me or have
the lights on
and you're not yeah it took it right
back to the late 1800s oh my god
it's like i was like do you really think
in this day and age
people still fall for that kind of crap
yeah you're not allowed to film
anything you're not allowed to have
lights on you don't
like watch what i'm doing because
obviously
oh i have to have music on really loud
because the spirits like the vibrations
i'm like oh
because you're trying to cover up the
noises if you like moving around and
like doing nefarious [ __ ]
duh it's like come on come on everybody
know that you skipped [ __ ] episode
two and three i skipped all of them
after one and like we watched like that
one and i was just kind of like falling
asleep
and then we watched part of the second
one then and then we skipped to the end
it's like yeah we'll talk about it
tomorrow
more detail dude man i just i just can't
i couldn't
i just like can we watch gordon now yeah
like can we watch people like cooking
more people are showing up in the damn
stream we've been streaming for [ __ ]
five hours oh now they're showing yeah
now they're showing
now that we're all [ __ ] like oh hey
what are you guys doing [ __ ] 10
o'clock at night dude we're drunk
what's happening drunk and combative
well and you have to go find pookie
because she's outside all right once you
go ahead and shut this [ __ ] down jenny
go ahead and shut it the [ __ ]
down all right shut it down thank you
shut it down
okay okay i will shut it down
are you sure you're done talking are you
sure okay yeah yeah i'm done talking you
done talking
i don't know i'm never sure when you're
done talking because he always talks
but yeah so um yeah we're going to shut
this down for the night sorry about all
the technical difficulties that
hopefully wasn't too much of a pain in
the ass i found it a huge pain in the
ass but hopefully
she loses her [ __ ] i was i was just like
god damn well
she was losing her [ __ ] well can you
understand why it's like i'm trying to
i'm trying to do a show i'm trying to
read my notes and
like my [ __ ] keep shutting down but yeah
we'll be back tomorrow about three
o'clock uh eastern standard time we're
going to talk about that surviving death
[ __ ] on netflix because like i said i
have some thoughts
so uh we'll talk about that you're
poking around yeah it'll be it'll be fun
yeah
so and think of your future we gotta go
find
poop
[Music]
yeah message to you pookie
i can't hold it i can't hold a note i'm
too drunk
you were doing all right all right all
right so go find pokey and then we're
gonna go to bed
and then we'll be back at three tomorrow
talking about life after death that'll
be fun
but yeah hopefully i covered all the
[ __ ] probably in but who cares
all right so we'll see you guys tomorrow
thanks for dropping by